what's been the biggest challenge that
you've had to overcome from a personal
aspect it was when I left the police to
transition into a new career I went
through a super super dark period from a
mental aspect I I was completely
completely lost so the biggest challenge
I've overcome is learning how to walk
away from a job which is fundamentally a
career moving to something which
everyone says you should follow your
passion I did that I began to hate it I
resented the thing that I was I loved
the most I really hated it I had no
money I was in a complete dark period
completely lost the biggest challenge I
overcome was overcoming the mental
aspects of Ash and then relearning who I
was having to relearn empathy one of my
friends came to me and said my grandma
passed away and I went okay well
unfortunately people died like that's
just part of life I'm not a friend there
I'm a robot so relearning the empathy
side of things of life was was really
interesting so from my perspective it's
overcoming the mental challenges of
myself that's the hardest thing I've
ever done when you can't leave a side of
it you're fearless and you're so
powerful you're literally like Superman
or woman because no one putting the
phone down on you can never hurt you